bienvenidos a este programa especial de
fin de año desde londres en el reino
unido donde el prestige sigue siendo el
gran protagonista casi un año después
del divorcio con la unión europea uno de
los primeros y grandes efectos ha sido
la falta de suministros de todo tipo y
de trabajadores de la unión europea el
break seed evidenció justamente la
dependencia de la mano de obra de esa
comunidad no sólo ha habido escasez de
recolectores de cosechas y de
conductores de grandes camiones sino en
todos los sectores según bloomberg sólo
en el 2020 200.000 europeos dejaron este
país por el break city y la pandemia del
coi 19 el gobierno y los analistas
explican que el país está viviendo un
periodo de adaptación y de transición
del que no hay certeza cuánto tiempo
durará y así lo explicamos en la
siguiente historia el reconocido
restaurante francés estrella michelín
piedade es uno de los negocios que está
sufriendo las consecuencias del texto
sus operaciones se han reducido en
cuanto a horario y trabajo por la falta
de empleados y largos trámites aduaneros
de
la juventud de europa que solía
disfrutar viniendo a londres sin
problema ahora tiene que tener un
patrocinio nuestros salarios en la
industria están por encima de lo normal
pagamos muy bien
pero no sólo han disminuido las horas de
atención al público también el menú ha
tenido que ser adaptado y preparado con
más ingredientes locales porque las
importaciones pueden durar incluso meses
tienden en gris y poseen en france
compraba a salvo en grecia comprabas
algo en francia tuviste tu logística
para resolverlo tenías quién lo iba a
conducir pero no se atascó en la aduana
y no se le retenía para pedir rescate
envié una caja de vino a un cliente de
irlanda hace cuatro semanas el cliente
todavía no lo tiene
y las consecuencias negativas del break
si también están afectando la mano de
obra calificada en varias áreas
primordiales en el sector de la salud
por ejemplo hay vacantes de 160 mil
puestos de trabajo sin profesionales
postulándose el autóloga mexicana gina
vega completó su equipo de trabajo ocho
meses después de empezar la búsqueda con
muchas enfermeras dentales y han
decidido regresar al este de europa
entonces hay hay pocas enfermeras
y calificadas enfermeras dentales
calificadas para trabajar con nosotros
en la consulta entonces muchas veces en
el pasado
había una vacancia y había
34 intereses por día
desgraciadamente ahora hay veces que
pasan semanas sin que nadie nos contacte
con su con su currículum la escases de
materiales esenciales fabricados en
países europeos y el sobreprecio de
hasta un 7% cuando se consiguen también
está afectando la labor de la odontóloga
ahora tenemos que esperar una semana a
diez días para recibir algún encargo o
alguna alguna compra mientras que antes
por ejemplo hablabas pedías los guantes
digamos y al día siguiente los teníamos
en el constructor ya casi un año después
de que el break city se hiciera efectivo
el país sigue adaptándose a una nueva
realidad con una economía golpeada pues
para algunos la adaptación ha sido un
poco como una ducha fría ha sido como un
shock el break shit tendrá un efecto a
más largo plazo eso es lo que dicen los
propios pronosticadores oficiales del
gobierno que el break si tendrá un
efecto doble en la economía que 'el
hobbit' tratando de aliviar la crisis
por falta de mano de obra el gobierno
flexibilizó temporalmente su sistema
migratorio
sin muchos resultados
el nuevo esquema hace que sea mucho más
difícil para las personas de la unión
europea' venir aquí pero en realidad
facilita que las personas del resto del
mundo vengan y trabajen aquí meses
después del divorcio con la unión
europea el break city sigue generando
tensiones inevitables con algunos
aliados sobre todo con francia por los
derechos pesqueros y los traspiés
continuarán mientras el reino unido- se
adapta a su nueva realidad
el 2022 trae otros nuevos desafíos no
solo resolver urgentemente la falta de
trabajadores londres y bruselas deben
lograr pronto un acuerdo en la creciente
disputa por el protocolo de irlanda del
norte que mantiene a esta región dentro
del mercado común y el sistema aduanero
de la unión europea lo que ha creado
entre otros escasez de alimentos porque
enviar un producto a irlanda del norte
el mismo país desde cualquier ciudad
británica es casi que una importación
por la cantidad de trámites que se
requieren ahora mientras la unión del
reino unido- tambalea el gobierno
escocés quiere realizar un segundo
referendo de independencia para el que
necesita el visto bueno del primer
ministro boris johnson quien por ahora
ha mantenido cerrada esa puerta